[Musik]
us-präsident jump in bedrängnis die
demokraten bereiten ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren vor trump
spricht von der grössten hexenjagd in
der us-geschichte entschädigung für
missbrauchsopfer bis zu 400.000 euro
könnte die katholische kirche künftig
den opfern von sexueller gewalt zahlen
warnung vor der globalen katastrophe das
eis schmilzt schneller das wetter wird
immer extremer sagt der weltklimarat in
seinem sonderbericht
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
mittwoch an meiner seite ist für den
sport christian otto ja hallo und amt
merkel tut nichts für die ukraine das
ist nur eines der zitate von
us-präsident trump die heute an die
öffentlichkeit kamen
nach heftigem druck hat das weiße haus
das protokoll eines telefongesprächs
veröffentlicht das in den usa seit tagen
heftig diskutiert wird
es geht um ein gespräch zwischen ihm und
dem ukrainischen präsidenten zielinski
gerichte über den inhalt hatten die
demokraten in der nacht dazu veranlasst
ein amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen jump
vorzubereiten
dazu gleich mehr zunächst oliver flammen
über das was dem us präsidenten
vorgeworfen wird es war im juli als der
us-präsident mit dem frisch gewählten
ukrainischen präsidenten selensky
telefonierte wie das weiße haus jetzt
bestätigte drängte trump selensky
ermittlungen gegen seinen demokratischen
rivalen joe biden in auftrag zu geben
salems gesagt dass eine hilfe zu trumps
vorwurf beiden habe in früheren jahren
als us-vizepräsident druck auf die
ukraine ausgeübt um
korruptionsermittlungen gegen seinen
sohn hunter zu verhindern
handarbeiten war damals für eine
gasfirma in der ukraine tätig der inhalt
des telefonats im juli war nach
medienberichten einem us geheimagenten
aufgefallen dessen vorgesetzte
verzichteten aber offenbar darauf gegen
trump zu ermitteln hat der us präsident
in diesem telefonat gegen gesetze
verstoßen mit dem versuch ermittlungen
gegen seinen demokratischen gegner
beiden zu erwirken
die demokraten wollen das jetzt prüfen
und jump gegebenenfalls des amtes
entheben er selbst bestreitet jegliche
einflussnahme aus washington ines trams
präsident trump in new york bei den
vereinten nationen doch seine gedanken
sind bei den vorwürfen gegen ihn
er spricht von der grössten hexenjagd
aller zeiten da war kein druck dieses
telefonat wurde aufgeblasen zu einem
anruf aus der hölle
dabei war es nicht viele sagten mir
danach selten hätten sie mich so nett
gesehen tramper kennt nichts
verwerfliches an seinem telefonat mit
dem ukrainischen präsidenten selensky
den drängte er gegen seinen politischen
rivalen joe biden und dessen sohn zu
ermitteln die mitschrift des telefonats
zeigt der ukrainer fragt nach
militärhilfe trump entgegnet wir würden
euch da allerdings noch um einen
gefallen bitten wollen die demokraten
vermuten machtmissbrauch wahlhilfe gegen
militärhilfe deren vorsitzende leitet
nun erste schritte zu einem
amtsenthebungsverfahren 1
der präsident hat gegen seine
verfassungsgemäße verantwortung
verstoßen indem er einen anderen staat
um wahl hilfe gebeten hat auf kosten
unserer nationalen sicherheit und
sauberer wollen die republikaner sind
anfangs seite ihr gegenangriff steht
unser job ist es uns um die menschen zu
kümmern ihr leben besser zu machen
unser job ist zu regieren und nicht
rückwärts gewandte ermittlungen zu
führen die nichts bringen nun ist es am
abgeordnetenhaus weiter zu ermitteln
klar ist es wird eine langwierige
schmutzige auseinandersetzung diese
schlacht sie hat gerade erst begonnen
der nachfrage bei unseren washington
korrespondenten m at wissen reicht das
jetzt von einem amtsenthebungsverfahren
eigentlich ja denn entscheidend ist
dabei nicht ob es so einen deal geben
sollte also militärhilfe gegen einen
gefallen den donald trump wollte sondern
entscheidend ist ob er tatsächlich eine
fremde macht aufgefordert hat schmutz zu
sammeln über einen politischen
widersacher und dann auch angeboten hat
den justizminister so die eigene
regierung einzuspannen für diesen zweck
wenn das bewiesen würde wäre das macht
missbrauchen die demokraten werden das
als hebel benutzt um alle anderen
vorwürfe von strafvereitlung bis
vorteilsnahme ebenfalls auf den tisch zu
bringen um dann gegenüber der
amerikanischen öffentlichkeit das so
überzeugend darzustellen dass auch diese
dann überzeugt ist dass dieser präsident
donald trump seinen amtseid verraten hat
am ende müsste aber auch der senat einer
amtsenthebung zu stimmen zustimmen wie
stehen da die chancen für tram also die
demokraten müssten mindestens 20
republikanische senatoren davon
überzeugen dass sie mit stimmen
deswegen muss diese argumentation so
klar und eindeutig sein dass ein solcher
im historischen moment dann auch die
republikaner nicht auf der falschen
seite der geschichte stehen wollen wenn
das nicht gelingt dann bleibt am ende
nur die wahl am 5 november 2020 wo
daneben die amerikanischen wähler
darüber entscheiden ob dieser
präsidentin dieses amt gehört oder eben
nicht
dankeschön für diese einschätzung
empathie wissen aus washington wie
telefonieren zwei präsidenten
miteinander und was genau hat der us
präsident über deutschland und die
bundeskanzlerin gesagt wenn sie der
wortlaut des protokolls interessiert
können sie es auf heute de nachlesen
hier finden sie das original so wie es
heute vom weißen haus veröffentlicht
wurde
nach deutschland durchschnittlich 5000
euro für ihr erlittenes leid bekommen
derzeit die männer und frauen die als
kinder oder jugendliche von katholischen
priestern missbraucht wurden
jetzt will die deutsche
bischofskonferenz diese entschädigung
neu regeln und wohl deutlich erhöhen
im gespräch sind zwei modelle entweder
könnte ein betroffener pauschal 300.000
euro bekommen oder je nach schwere des
falls zwischen 40.000 und 400.000 euro
eine studie der katholischen kirche geht
von fast 3700 opfern aus die
dunkelziffer dürfte deutlich höher sein
denken klinge berichtet für matthias
katsch von der opfervereinigung eckiger
tisch ist dieser tag ein meilenstein
die deutschen bischöfe haben den weg
frei gemacht für eine neue regelung für
die opfer sexuellen missbrauchs
er selbst hat die vorgeschlagenen
modelle mit erarbeitet
es ist nicht ganz einfach für ein opfer
sexueller gewalt
hierzu stehen oder hier zu sein und es
geht auch nicht nur um die tat oder die
taten sondern es geht um die folgen im
leben der betroffenen aus diesen taten
entschädigungen von bis zu 400.000 euro
sind im gespräch endgültig haben die
bischöfe sich aber noch nicht auf
bestimmte summen festgelegt sie wollen
einzelheiten bald klären
ein appell heißt ja immer bitte nicht
sozusagen auf die lange bank schieben
das machen wir nicht sondern es ist klar
es geht jetzt darum zügig auf der
grundlage dieses modells die weiteren
fragen die sie stellen zu klären der
missbrauchsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung wertet die beratungen
der bischöfe als ein positives signal
ich hoffe dass fulda jetzt wegweisende
entscheidungen getroffen hat und das
möglichst bald betroffene in den genuss
von angemessenen entschädigung kommen
jetzt sehen viele opfer die bischöfe in
der pflicht gemeinsam mit ihren
bistümern eine konkrete entscheidung zu
treffen
die thomascook pleite schlägt weiter
wellen zwar kann condor weiter fliegen
dank eines millionenkredits der
bundesregierung die tochter thomas cook
deutschland musste allerdings ebenfalls
insolvenz anmelden
das unternehmen mit den marken
neckermann bucher öger tours und air
marin will sich so sanieren
auf dem spiel stehen etwa 2000
arbeitsplätze direkt sowie mehrere
zehntausend in reisebüros etwa 97.000
urlauber sind derzeit mit thomas cook
unterwegs berichtet axel konrad die
letzten tage auf kreta hätte sich an den
mikros unbeschwerter gewünscht belastend
seien die nachrichten über die pleite
von thomas cook und condor gewesen jetzt
ist die angst groß dass die heimreise
platz wir haben erst vor zwei tagen
erfahren dass condor pleite ist und wir
sind schon besorgt dass wir nicht mehr
nach hause kommen condor fliegt vorerst
weiter so viel ist seit gestern abend
klar denn da kam die zusage für geld vom
staat 380 millionen euro
überbrückungskredit und die andere
thomas cook tochter die deutsche thomas
cook wer mit ihr unterwegs ist der ist
heute auch schon ein wenig schlauer denn
durch den insolvenzantrag springt jetzt
die versicherung ein
unsere kunden vor ort können jetzt damit
rechnen dass ihre reise wieder
reibungslos stattfinden kann
dass die diskussionen der letzten tage
vorbei sind noch mal ein großer
entschuldigung für diese situation
die versicherungssumme ist allerdings
gedeckelt auf 110 millionen euro
und die teilen sich womöglich
hunderttausende urlauber 97.000 kunden
sind derzeit noch mit thomas cook im
urlaub weitere 660.000 haben dort reisen
gebucht und zumindest schon eine
anzahlung geleistet
im schlimmsten falle wird die
entschädigung sehr dürftig seien
das ist die frage die alle bewegt ob die
versicherungssumme ausreicht das kann
man zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht
sagen
was man sagen kann ist dass das reise
insolvenzrecht für solche
großinsolvenzen eigentlich nicht
geschaffen ist
zwei tage nach der pleite von thomas
cook gibt es für die kunden einige
antworten aber noch viel mehr fragen
regelmäßige wirbelstürme
überschwemmungen der küstenmetropole
inseln die untergehen
in seinem neuen bericht zeichnet der
weltklimarat ein alarmierendes bild über
die zukunft unseres planeten
wenn sich nichts ändert so warnen die
experten könnten kleinere gletscher in
den nächsten 80 jahren vier fünftel
ihrer eismasse verlieren
zudem werde der meeresspiegel immer
schneller und immer weiter steigen die
folge überflutungen für die
wissenschaftler ist klar die menschen
müssen schnell etwas ändern und sich auf
extremes wetter vorbereiten
aus berlin andreas ruppert südostasien
hier ist es besonders sichtbar denn hier
bieten sie in den letzten jahren
besonders oft extremwetterereignisse wie
wirbelstürme sturmfluten und starkregen
dann wird zum beispiel damit zu tun dass
sie meeresspiegelanstieg haben und
gleichzeitig eine zunahme von extremen
niederschlägen und gleichzeitig eine
zunahme in der intensität von
wirbelsturm ereignissen und gleichzeitig
eine zunahme von extremereignissen auch
in der häufigkeit matthias geschlagen
hat am sonderbericht des weltklimarats
mitgearbeitet heute in monaco
vorgestellt zeigen sich darin speziell
die auswirkungen des klimawandels auf
eisschmelze und weltmeere
der befund so eindeutig wie
besorgniserregend die erderwärmung
verändert das leben in und um die ozeane
dramatisch ohne effektiven klimaschutz
müssen wir bis ende des jahrhunderts
einen weiteren anstieg des
meeresspiegels von allein 84 zentimetern
erwarten
allein in europa hätte das direkte
folgen für 13 millionen menschen
angesichts dieser lage fordern die
grünen von der bundesregierung dass die
ihr klimapaket nachbessert es muss
endgültig schluss sein mit pille palle
beim klimaschutz und es ist dramatisch
dass die bundesregierung dies
funktionales sogenanntes
klimaschutzpaket heute auch im kabinett
noch bestätigt hat
die umweltministerin kann sich durchaus
nachbesserungen heißt verschärfungen
vorstellen zb beim co2 ausstoß im
verkehrsbereich
also ich denke dass wir in dem bereich
des verkehrs sehr sehr optimistische
schätzungen haben und dass ich dem
verkehrsminister wünsche dass die
schätzungen so eintreten aber nicht ganz
sicher wenn das das wirklich so kommt
klimawandel gefährdet unser leben das
zeigt der pcc bericht deutlich die
politik muss geeignete instrumente
finden für ihren kampf gegen den
klimawandel erhält greta thunberg den
alternativen nobelpreis die junge
schwedin habe millionen menschen
inspiriert politisches handeln
einzufordern heißt es in der begründung
auch die menschenrechtlerin aminatu
haidar aus der westsahara die
chinesische frauenrechtlerin guru john
mayer und der brasilianische ureinwohner
daviko penava werden mit dem
alternativen nobelpreis ausgezeichnet
das britische parlament eigentlich hätte
dort heute exakt gar nichts passieren
sollen zwangspause so hatte es premier
jones ja gewollt
doch bekanntlich sagen die obersten
richter das anders also tagt das
parlament wieder und wie noch
leidenschaftlicher als sonst bringen die
abgeordneten um eine lösung aus der
black cit krise dreieinhalb wochen
bleiben ihnen diana zimmermann
es hatte einen schon fast gefehlt das
spektakel nun und nichtig sei die
aufhebung des parlaments vor zwei wochen
gewesen hatte der oberste gerichtshof
gestern entschieden der erste
sitzungstag nach der unfreiwilligen
pause sollte nicht enttäuschen
der rechtsberater der regierung war
aufgefordert zu erklären wie es zu
seiner gesetzeswidrigen empfehlung
gekommen war
doch jeffrey cox entschied sich für
angriff statt verteidigung
[Musik]
dieses parlament ist ein totes parlament
die abgeordneten sollten mutig genug
sein sich den wählern zu stellen aber
vielen wir geht es nur darum unseren
austritt aus der eu zu vereiteln
doch die zeit wird kommen da auch diese
trainer weihnachten nicht mehr
verhindern können
das war zu viel für so manchen auf der
anderen seite des ehrwürdigen hauses in
einem ihrer worte heute findet sich auch
nur die spur von scham darüber dass sie
versucht haben dieses raus und unsere
demokratie lang kollegen dass sie ihre
partei und die premier es wagen über
anstand und moral zu sprechen ist eine
schande vorzeitig kam der premier vom
klimagipfel aus new york zurück um sich
am nachmittag den fragen der
abgeordneten zu stellen
doch die warten immer noch von boris
johnson bis jetzt keine spur 30 jahre
nach dem mauerfall sieht die
bundesregierung die deutsche einheit auf
einem guten weg nach ihrem aktuellen
bericht stieg die wirtschaftskraft im
osten
verglichen mit der des westens von 43
prozent im jahr 1990 auf 75 prozent im
jahr 2018 die arbeitslosenquote im osten
sank vom höchststand 2005 auf nur noch
6,9 prozent 2008 10
zum vergleich im westen lag sie bei 4,8
prozent
und damit sind wir beim sport christin
und zwei weltmeisterschaft so richtige
saison highlights mit gold für den
australischen titelverteidiger un dennis
ging das einzelzeitfahren der männer bei
den straßenrad-weltmeisterschaften in
yorkshire zu ende
bester deutscher zwölf tage nach seinem
schlimmen sturz bei der vuelta
tony martin als neunter völlig erschöpft
im ziel gezeichnet von den strapazen der
hügeligen 54 kilometer langen
strecke die folgen aus dem sturz bei der
spanien-rundfahrt machten tony martin
mehr zu schaffen als er hofft vor allem
beim luftholen unter der großen
belastung habe gefühlt hatte wirklich
noch zu kämpfen
ich hatte immer noch darauf dass das was
ich kriegen dass sich auch die formation
wird
dem war nicht so rang 9 wird es für den
viermaligen einzel zeitfahr-weltmeister
knapp zweieinhalb minuten hinter dem
sieger ron dennis der australier
triumphiert wie schon im letzten jahr
und gewinnt deutlich vor dem belgier
remko winnetou links und dem italiener
filippo ghana wo er im wüstenstaat katar
ist von freitag an ausrichter der
leichtathletik weltmeisterschaften
ein umstrittener austragungsort vor
allem auch wegen der extremen hitze hier
in der sprechen die meisten von zwei
klimazonen draußen bis zu 40 grad und
drinnen wird alles von klimaanlagen
bestimmt auch im stadion deutschlands
top sprinterin derzeit hat jana pinto
beim stadionfest 25 grad sind es heute
abend erträglich weil geld irgendwie
keine rolle spielt der sport soll
globalisiert werden so wünscht es sich
auch der vor wenigen stunden wieder
gewählte präsident des
leichtathletik-weltverbandes sebastian
co drängende probleme wie das thema
doping oder eben auch die hitze hier
lächelt er weg der sport soll nun im
vordergrund stehen aus deutscher sicht
könnte das schlusstag der wm ein
goldener werden mit der weltjahresbesten
im weitsprung malaika me hamburg doha
ist bereit die athleten ebenfalls
freitag geht es los samstag dann live im
zdf als klar und wir haben jetzt noch
die lottozahlen die gewinnzahlen lauten
57 15 23 33 37 und die superzahl 8
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
das wetter wird wechselhaft und windig
die details hat gleich katja horneffer
für sie das heute journal mit claus
kleber um viertel vor zehn und hier
begrüßt sie morgen petra gerster wir
wünschen ihnen noch einen unbeschwerten
abend machen sie es gut auch wieder
wählen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren als
ganz normales tief ist der ehemalige
hurrikan umberto bei uns angekommen hat
regen mitgebracht wind und nur wenig
sonne aber den regen können wir immer
noch gut gebrauchen
in den vergangenen drei tagen sind im
westen und südwesten durchaus zehn bis
40 liter regen pro quadratmeter oder
millimeter gefallen nur nordosten da ist
es bisher noch relativ trocken geblieben
das wird sich in den nächsten tagen
ändern
heute nacht bildet sich im nordosten
erstmal nebel im westen regnet es bei 14
bis 8 grad
und dieser nebel der muss ich morgen
vormittag im nordosten erstmal auflösen
dann aber scheint doch mal kurz die
sonne und auch an den alpen werden sie
morgen vormittag die sonne sehen kann
der regen allerdings kommt von westen
heran und bis zum nachmittag oder frühen
abend erreicht der schleswig holstein
den harz in thüringer wald den
bayerischen und oberpfälzer wald der
wind dazu kommt aus südlichen richtungen
und die temperaturen steigen am
alpenrand auf 15 grad in magdeburg in
der lausitz um die 21 grad in den
nächsten tagen geht es vor allen dingen
im süden recht freundlich weiter und da
wird es auch waren über den norden
ziehen immer wieder regenschauer hinweg
schönen abend noch